hey guys what's up this is andrew for
jensenses.com
so today i want to make a big analysis
guys on a lot of different stocks that i
used to talk
a lot about i mean i still gonna talk
about them
but you know that i'm mostly talking
about amc and gamestop because
this is what is very hard at the moment
but i don't want to forget about those
other stocks that i like to talk about
so today i want to make
an update on football tv on tesla on
blackberry
and on bbkcf for the first time because
someone asked me to do it in the
comments so i'm doing it
so let's get into it
[Music]
and guys let's start with football tv
okay fubu tv is a stock that
i used to talk about a lot a few months
ago
so i'm not gonna make the full story
here but basically
i was telling you guys that we're gonna
go down you know in feb
i told you that we're gonna go down to
20 that probably we're going to bounce
back
and that then after 20 got broken i told
you we go to 15
and then we're gonna strongly bounce
back all right looks a bit like the
bitcoin by the way and this is what
happened so what is
really funny on this chart guys is that
i
still have my drawings that i did on
the 16th of april so you can go and
check my video i published that day
this drawing is here so it's not
perfect it's not going exactly to the
same level but it's roughly
going to the same area and so here what
is important to notice guys is that we
had
this breakout that occurred at 20. i
told you guys
same thing i told you we have the
breakout that now we're gonna move
higher
so that we're gonna complete a one two
three four five which
i think we are completing right now guys
uh we are now doing the fifth wave of
the first wave
so i'm of course very bullish on this
i'm gonna tell you my target very soon
but first i think that we're gonna have
this correction coming soon usually when
wave three is extended guys
it's this situation so wave one is equal
to wave
five so here i think that the
fifth wave is gonna roughly go to the 35
area you know something like this
because it's going to be equal to wave 1
35 37 then we're gonna correct
then usually the second wave it likes to
correct to the bottom of the false wave
so i think that we're going to correct
to 26 so here you might have a buying
opportunity
guys if you want to enter this train and
here same thing
and we could also go a bit lower guys we
could go to the bottom of the false wave
here
so either we go to 23 or we go to 26 27
so those are my levels of retracement
that i think the second wave would go to
you can also double check this with fibs
you measure
the wave let's see let's say it goes
here and it's probably going to go to
the 50
of the 61.8 percent so 25 22 so you can
see
we're using different methods we have
the same area of buying
so the buying power would probably be
sitting here
and then we're gonna do three four five
and for the levels
so i measured the first wave this was
corrective one two
the first wave is here bum and i applied
to the bottom
of the second wave and the 1.618
extension level is the one that i think
we're going to so around
100 so i think that fubo is going to 100
but i'm not sure when maybe like in a
few weeks month
so let's see for now we need to wait for
this correction and then we're gonna do
the third wave
four and five so we have time i'm gonna
keep updating you guys on this but this
is looking good
expect some correction coming soon
though and get ready for the third wave
then tesla so tesla guys nothing much
that's why i didn't make an update i can
quickly update you guys i told you
here that we are bullish that we
finished so it was in may starting one
month ago
i told you we are bullish we completed
the fourth wave for me abc
so i think the abc is complete once
again you never know it can be slightly
extended so
be a bit careful here but to me this abc
is complete what you guys want to see is
a breakout of the trend line
connecting the highs of this abc so
something like this
so this is going to be a good entry
level for example if you're still not in
this trade
you wait for the breakout you buy the
re-test as usual and in terms of targets
so here the situation is a bit different
because we're having
wave one and wave three extended so it's
a bit funny
so i'm not sure if the fixed wave is
going to be that long all right
so the first scenario is that
the fifth wave so once again it's a
golden number ratio but the 0.618 so
maybe only 1070.
so this is one possibility if you look
at the book
it's this one so here the fifth wave is
equal
to 0.618 percent of the
1.3 so you have this relation
here and in this situation tesla goes to
1070 but
if we're having a fixed wave extended as
well so it's possible
we would go to the 1.618 percentage
extension which is 1962. so let's say
two thousand so i still believe that for
me my preferred scenario is two thousand
yes because i'm very bullish on tesla
i'm very bullish basically on everything
because of all the money that
is in the economy guys so that's why i'm
so bullish on everything that is hot
tesla used to be very hot it's gonna be
hot again i really think this so
let's see but to me the 1.618
extension level is more likely to happen
than the 0.618
blackberry so blackberry guys what do we
have here
so i'm using guys always the same method
so here we have the nice breakout
that occurred in the third wave so one
two three
four we're doing the fifths guys the
third wave is the one that is the
strongest with the
bigger volume and that is taking back
some major level which here
is the breakout level around six or
seven area
we retested it as usual and then we did
the fifth wave of the third wave then we
are correcting the correction is quite
deep
but it was expected guys here so we went
on in may here so the fourth wave has
been complete here on the 15th of may
and now we are just doing a one two
three four five that is probably going
to be extended as well guys here
i'm saying it's gonna be extended
because i just look at the first wave
you know and you can already feel that
this is gonna be extended when this
first wave is so massive so intense
usually you have an extended fixed wave
you know
i don't imagine we have like small three
four five it's going to be extended
waves as well
here so knowing that here
in terms of entry level so i gave you
guys this level uh 12.6
we traded there a few times already last
week yes so
if you wanted to enter this trade you
know it's 0.618
percentage retracement of fibonacci so i
told you guys this in my previous video
it's a nice level to buy so maybe you
are industry
already if you're not you can still
maybe have an opportunity to be
done at this level if you want to get in
and then in terms of level so i think
the third wave is going to start soon
guys
it's going to start soon i don't have a
precise timing you know we need to see
like you know some strong moves up with
some momentum coming so probably if we
start to trade above 40 and 15
it's gonna come with some momentum of
course and in terms of targets guys once
again if the fifth wave is extended you
measure the third wave you applied to
the bottom of the first wave and you
come up with
46 as a target so this is my target for
blackberry
and last one guys i don't even know the
stock bbkcf
but i'm here to you know analyze what
you guys asking me to analyze
so let's do it so we have a nice bullish
development i don't have a lot of data i
have like three years of data but
it's already more than enough i'm just
gonna lie you know here i'm seeing that
a new move has started from here with
one two this is only a three it's a
three because inside that
i can count one two three four five the
third wave looks
finished complete to me and i think
we're just starting the correction
of the false wave so expect this force
wave usually to go
to the top of the third or to the bottom
of the force
okay so i would be a buyer around 53
wow or 20 27 all right all this area
okay between 30 and 55 basically i would
be a buyer i think that we're going to
consolidate more this looks weak to me
and this is not a correction complete
yes
this is only a a so we need a b and a c
so i think that this stuff is going down
and then we're gonna of course
bounce back it's totally to talk about
targets because i'm not sure that
where the force wave might go but after
the false wave is complete we can go
quite high guys you know there is a lot
of room on the upside
so that's it for me i hope you guys
enjoyed this video i hope that this was
helpful
if you have some positions in the stock
so if you want to enter
the stocks to see what kind of
techniques i would use to enter these
positions or
to exit and fight some targets so if you
enjoyed this video please don't forget
to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore see you guys